silk road often referred to as the ebay
for drugs
it sounds like the plot of a movie a u.s
man was able to hide behind a false
identity
operating a sophisticated illegal drug
website
the fbi calls it the most sophisticated
criminal marketplace on the internet
thousands of drug dealers used it to
sell drugs and completely hide their
identities
a new website sells illegal anyone who
was willing to pay
silk road silk road silk road silk
road silk road this is ross obrecht he's
the founder of the silk road
the first online marketplace on the dark
web where you can buy and sell
anything and i mean anything from stuff
that you smoke to things that go boom to
even body parts and assassinations
and all of it will be shipped right to
your door by the federal government's
postal service and some cleverly
disguised packages
the first real world application i had
ever heard of in bitcoin was called silk
road
it was launched in 2011. it was a
website
accessible through an ip address uh
obscuring software where users could buy
and sell things
in a censorship resistant and free way
it quickly became bitcoin's first major
use case
the site went so viral that by age 28
ross was on track to become a
billionaire within just two years
and the silk road community called him
the steve jobs of the online drug world
and if the silk road was a startup at
its peak it would have easily been
considered a unicorn the elusive term
for a startup that's worth over a
billion dollars
and at that peak in 2012 this is what
ross had to say when asked by his friend
where he wanted to be in 20 years from
now
this was before anyone knew he was the
man behind the silk road
i want to have had a substantial
positive impact on
the future of humanity by that time do
you think you're gonna live forever
i think it's a possibility i honestly do
i think i might
live further in some form
[Music]
ross already knew he was going down in
history but not as the hero the free
people from the tyranny of the us war on
drugs as he hoped people will remember
him as
but as a villain a villain that got
people addicted that got people killed
america's very own kingpin and internet
kingpin
and less than three years after the site
launched he was arrested charged with
seven felonies and since not to one but
two life sentences
plus 40 years in prison without parole
as a first-time non-violent offender
and now he'll spend the rest of his life
in prison for it which is really a
shocking outcome of this i don't think
anyone expected such a harsh sentence
the prosecution wasn't even asking for
it were they i covered cyber crime for a
technology magazine i've never heard
of such a long sentence for something
someone did with the computer
essentially
he was ordered to serve two life
sentences plus 40 years in prison
despite the fact that he was a
first-time offender convicted of no
violent crimes
he served almost eight years of that
sentence to date
can you hold an alleged website host
responsible
for the actions of users on his site
this is internet kingpin
the epic rise and fall of the criminal
mastermind behind the silk road
a story that spans multiple continents
filled with corrupt cops paid
assassinations
lots and lots and lots of money and a
road to help pay with the good
intentions of a young idealistic genius
very sophisticated very intellectual
individual who took
those skills and those talents and
developed an
online website that marketed
illegal goods illegal services
investigators say ullbrick tried to
execute a murder for hire on that user
offering 150 thousand dollars to a
would-be hitman
part of why you know you want to speak
out a little bit is you're frustrated
absolutely the most frustrating thing is
that evidence
that is favorable favorable to ross is
being suppressed the
operator made 80 million dollars in fees
it used tor and bitcoin to protect
people's privacy
i called it an anonymous market at the
time i thought
if bitcoin makes payments anonymous and
private then what are we waiting for
why are we sitting around talking about
it let's put it into action
that's impulsive that's a
26 year old who thinks i think she has
to save the world before someone beats
him to it
sometime later this century i'll grow
old and die
i'll finally leave prison but i'll be in
a body bag
[Music]
one of the things you could buy on the
silk road was a very popular substance
that comes in the form of a white powder
that acts as a stimulant that gives you
loads of energy and confidence that is
very popular on wall street the problem
with this substance is that it's
addictive has bad long-term side effects
and is maybe a little illegal
just overall not good for you luckily
for you you don't have to resort to
buying this stuff off the dark web if
you want loads of energy and confidence
because we have genius consciousness
a phenomenal nootropic that i take
almost every day to put my brain into
high gear if you guys have never tried a
nootropic before you are sorely missing
out especially
if you're trying to do something big
with your life like ross the best way i
can explain what taking a nootropic
feels like is that it's kind of like
nitrous from the fast and the furious
but for your brain the gears start
turning faster there's less friction
with your thoughts you just feel
sharper with less brain fog a complete
nine day difference i take the stuff
almost every day i'm doing heavily
creative work and i am never going back
all you have to do is get water
genius consciousness spoon
and it lasts me throughout the entire
time i'm working and the way you should
think about this stuff is as an
investment if taking this leads to me
making more money than not taking this
then i'm actually losing out on money by
not buying this and i'm fairly certain
that the extra creative boost this gives
me gives me a much higher roi than what
this actually costs out of pocket
it's clinically proven with trademark
ingredients that are all natural there's
no prescription work card and they have
over 17 000 reviews on amazon
and genius was founded by my good friend
robert oliver who is a certified badass
not just some internet marketer that
puts
entrepreneur in his bio and rob is
giving you guys a special ten percent
off when you go to the geniusbrand.com
jtn and use code jake tran at checkout
that's the geniusbrand.com
jake tran with code jaytran with the
link below pause the video do it right
now and back to the video
ross albert grew up in austin texas in
the late 80s and 90s
his father taught ross how to think
through every side of an argument and
his mother gave up her dream of becoming
a journalist to bet everything on her
golden sun becoming successful
and ross's story really begins when he
went to college at penn state like most
people who end up changing the world or
at least tried to he was a very smart
and equally eccentric guy
he was an extreme minimalist not caring
about material possessions wearing
hand-me-down clothes
living in a basement that kind of thing
that's where he met his long-term
girlfriend julia bay who always said how
cheap he was
one night julian noticed a bunch of
bucks near his bed and asked what they
were he explained that he was a part of
the college libertarians club a group
that discussed libertarian philosophy
economics and politics when julia asked
what libertarianism is
he explained that everything from what
you do with your life to what you put in
your body should be up to the individual
not the government and ross became
obsessed with libertarianism he would
tell his ideas to anyone that would
listen he would travel around the
country to attend libertarian
conferences he had an answer to every
possible political argument and
objection and a one-school debate ross
already led drugs all drugs should be
legalized
that not only is it not the government's
right to tell people what they can and
can't put in their bodies
but that legalizing drugs will actually
make society safer
how can you legalize something that
kills tens of thousands of people a year
that republican and democrat students
argued and ross counters
should we outlaw big macs from
mcdonald's too because people gain
weight and have heart attacks and die as
a result of them
should we outlook cars because people
get into car accidents and die
there are no gang wars over the sale of
alcohol or big mechs because those are
legal
millions of lives are ruined most of the
time over harmless drugs thrown into the
prison industrial complex
all because the government wanted to
tell people what they can and can't deal
with their bodies
needless to say ross won that debate the
only problem was that theoretical
debates were great and all but what
would he actually do with his life that
both align with his libertarian beliefs
make him a build load of money and make
his parents proud of him at the same
time so he dropped out of college moved
back to austin with his girlfriend
and started his hunt for that golden
idea
[Music]
ross seemingly tried everything he
started a video game company an
investment fund did odd jobs on
craigslist but nothing was working
nothing i've done has worked out he
complained i really haven't accomplished
anything great
i want to see some results i want to be
an entrepreneur but i've tried all these
different things and nothing has worked
i want to build something that is really
successful
but then an idea struck him an anonymous
website where you can buy and sell
anything things especially drugs that
people couldn't get their hands on
because of governments like the us
that way instead of having to buy your
favorite substance in person with some
sketchy dealer you can buy from the
comfort and safety of your own home
if it took off ross fantasized the us
government would eventually have to
legalize drugs
and it would be proof that the best way
to stop drug violence was to legalize it
it had the potential to completely
change the fabric of society
and he would be hailed as the person
that single-handedly entered the war on
drugs while at the same time making a
killing and making his parents proud
it used tore and bitcoin to protect
people's privacy
i called it an anonymous market at the
time i thought
if bitcoin makes payments anonymous and
private then what are we waiting for
why are we sitting around talking about
it let's put it into hatch
and by 2009 the anonymous browser tour
was already a thing
and the last missing piece of technology
ross would need was released bitcoin
bitcoin made me feel like anything was
possible
i got so excited i thought with bitcoin
i can try to do something that
actually makes a difference i was trying
to do something good
i was trying to help us move toward a
freer and more equitable world
but we all know the road to hell is
paved with good intentions right
and now here i am i'm in hell
to explain how the tor network works and
why i was instrumental in making the
silk road possible
here's my good friend kaya from sliding
to explain
let me explain how the tor network works
when your computer or phone connects to
the internet say
to youtube you are creating a connection
between two
computers essentially because youtube in
the end the server is
is a computer right since youtube uses
https
that's the little lock on your browser
the information that you send to youtube
is encrypted that is the message you
send say
your login information and your password
that can't really be read by anybody
only by youtube itself to talk to
youtube however it's our cloud server
your connection needs to go through the
internet through your internet service
provider which speaks to other servers
and then roots that connection finally
to reach the
youtube server now the problem there
is people could be snooping around
that network they might not be able to
figure out what exactly you sent
but they could definitely know that this
computer on one side
connected to this address that could go
from hackers
to patrols to of course the government
and
the police or even foreigners
now youtube or any site that you connect
to
will will know your address they'll know
what your ip address is which means that
they can easily find out
who you are or where you are so why
would you want to avoid this well
maybe you don't want anybody snooping
around your web activity because you're
being careful
maybe you do confidential work or maybe
yes maybe you're trying to start an
online black market and if somebody
found out what you're doing
you and your users would all end up
arrested
[Music]
so to avoid this the tor network
was invented by the us army no less and
if you want to use it on your computer
all you have to do is install the tor
browser so instead of connecting
directly to that server what your
computer is going to do is it's going to
use a set of relay computers that
anybody
even you could host you could host a
really computer if you wanted to and
they're going to be called
nodes now internet communication
calls messages website requests it all
works by sending
packets of data so each packet contains
a piece of information just a piece of
the whole puzzle maybe a fraction of
text or an image
or a video and then what tori is going
to do
is it's going to wrap those packets in
layers
just like an onion so your computer is
going to establish
a communication with each one of those
nodes and it's going to give them a key
so the first node only really has the
key
to the password to unlock the first
layer of this
so they can they can remove the layer
they certainly know where it came from
but it doesn't know what's inside the
onion
all the information they get is hey
please forward me here now after that
the message will move to the second note
and the second note
can do the same thing they can remove
another layer and
after removing that layer all it knows
is it needs to move the packet to
somewhere else
it knows where it came from but that's
no longer the original destination and
it knows it needs to be forwarded
somewhere so
the third note is special the third note
is called an exit though
[Music]
and then that third node can remove a
final layer
so it can't still read the message if
the server that you're connecting to
is encrypted it has https but it
definitely knows the final destination
of the message it just has no way of
knowing where it came from so
if anybody is listening through this
whole connection all they can really see
are encrypted messages being forwarded
from one node
to the other but no way of knowing the
origin or
the final destiny and that's how the tor
network works now can the network be
hacked
well yes it does have some weaknesses
especially towards that exit node
but i'm not gonna hijack jake's video
thanks kaya i'm featured in the video on
the influencer economy which will be
linked below
slybean in my opinion has the best
startup content on youtube with some
insane production quality so make sure
you subscribe with the link below
by the summer of 2010 ross started
working on what would become the silk
road
and it was no easy task it was basically
the equivalent of building ebay or
amazon on your own without any knowledge
experience or funding
so we had to teach himself fret and
embarking code on the fly and plus since
it was illegal there was no one he could
turn to for help when he ran into coding
issues
but little by little the site came
together but there was still one problem
he couldn't market the site for
potential sellers to sell on it so where
was he gonna get the product to sell on
the website to start
out the solution he read a dummy's guide
on building your own mushroom farm
rented out a building in the middle of
nowhere and grew his own inventory
an investment that cost him around
seventeen thousand dollars and kind of
landed him in prison for five to ninety
nine years in texas
being that the silk road would end up
generating him around 80 million dollars
in fees
this original 17 000 investment would
give him a staggering half a million
percent return
[Music]
the end of january 2011. it's been
around half a year since ross first
started working on the silk road and
today it was finally time for opening
day
by now ross had essentially done the
work of a 12-person startup he was the
front-end developer back-end developer
database expert tora expert bitcoin
expert
ceo ceo investor and so on some
estimates say it would have cost at
least around a million dollars of
funding to replicate the sites and he
still didn't know if anyone wanted to
use it but he felt that in some strange
cosmic way
this site was why he was here to free
people from the tyranny of an impressive
government he double checked everything
from the product inventory to the
database and server and boom
the silk road was live and here's how it
works
first you download the tor browser then
you type in this url in the tor browser
and then the website with the iconic
green camo logo appeared from there you
can navigate to your favorite product
categories the one product listed
where's mushrooms and then you bought
some bitcoin
just like you would buy tokens at an
arcade ross had written some
instructions on silk road's blog about
how to do that and then you would buy
the package would be shipped to your
doorstep and afterwards you would leave
a review to keep the marketplace healthy
and drive out bad sellers
and to get people to know about the site
ross had a simple marketing strategy
at exactly 4 20 pm on january 27th
ross went on relevant forms and acted
like a random person who just came
across a silk road and was recommending
it to people
and it worked people were already
browsing the site in no time after a few
weeks
ross was shipping out orders once or
twice a week he would vacuum seal the
product
and ship them off in padded envelopes at
this point the postal service didn't
have many resources
all the high-tech equipment to check for
illegal stuff was reserved for big
shipments
and sniffing dogs only came in a few
times a month and after a couple months
of business
he was now shipping out products daily
and he was no longer the only seller on
the sites a few new sellers joined the
rank selling harder stronger products
this made his girlfriend worried because
selling harder products could attract
trouble compared to selling more
harmless substances but ross became
obsessed and by march 2011 two months
into business
ross had already made a few thousand
dollars in revenue
[Music]
eventually the site caught the attention
of a journalist i wrote about internet
culture named adrian chen
when he first heard about it he thought
for sure it had to be a hoax because who
would be stupid enough to make a site
like this
but then he went to the website and
found out for himself he saw exactly 343
different kinds of products available
all for street prices are less than
street prices he created an account
named adrian802 then he posted on the
forum asking if anyone wanted to be
anonymously interviewed for the article
one guy a software developer said buying
products on the silk road
kind of felt like i was in the future
ross saw the journalist snooping around
and figured that there was no way to
stop him from writing the article so he
might as well use it as a way to get his
libertarian message out there
so he gave the journalist this statement
stop funding the state with your tax
dollars and direct your productive
energies towards the black market
and at 4 20 pm june 1 2011 adrian's
article went live on gawker the
underground website where you can buy
any drug imaginable
and the first paragraph read making
small talk where your pot dealer sucks
buying cocaine can get you shot what if
you could buy and sell drugs online like
books or light bulbs
now you can welcome to silk road
after the article was published it went
viral everyone was talking about every
news outlet was talking about and
subsequently traffic to the site
exploded and so did the price of bitcoin
a new website sells illegal dreams to
anyone who was willing to pay
you're talking about that psychedelic
store yes where you can buy anything you
want
yes there's a store that if you set up
your computer correctly
like you have to put like some kind of
make it random like ip addresses so it's
not trackable
then you can access to this access one
website called the silk roads
yeah but then just four days later the
silk road also caught the attention of
the us government
senator chuck schumer stood in front of
a podium in front of national tv
and this is what he had to say it's a
certifiable one-stop shop for illegal
drugs that represents the most brazen
attempt to peddle drugs online that we
have ever seen it's more brazen than
anything else by
light years and he called for the doj
and dea to shut down the site
immediately ross had picked a fight with
the biggest bully on earth and they were
about to fight back
ross turned to his girlfriend and said
they painted a bullseye on my back
the government would come to tremble at
the thought of the silk road not simply
because it sold substances but because
it threatened their power it threatened
their control they viewed it as a direct
attack on the very fabric of america
whoever was behind the silk road was
using the internet built by the
government a browser built by the
government
the postal service built by the
government to brazenly break the law
right in front of their eyes and there
was nothing the government could do
about it
in their eyes america was under attack
but not with 747s flying into buildings
but it was being
attacked in slow motion through a
website that wanted to topple the
country's democracy the silk road wasn't
just some traditional racket
it was a lucrative startup and just like
how google started with search engines
and now i've branched out into things
like self-driving cars
the problem with the silkworm was also
what it could be it had to be stopped
dead in his tracks before the movement
caught on and became too powerful
or in other words ross ulbricht was
outshining the master
eight months have gone by since chuck
schumer called up the silk road and the
site has been booming like crazy
and the media taunted the government for
not taking him down yet i am just amazed
that a website like this can stay up for
so long it was around this time that a
key agent from the department of
homeland security joins the hunts
leading up to this point ross had just
been going by the name admin on the
sites
but him and his new anonymous business
partner named vijay came up with a new
nickname for ross
dredd pirate roberts from the movie the
princess bride and the silk road
community ate
it up before ross was just a faceless
admin but now he was a feared pirate
taking on the us government it was a
rally call for everyone involved
you weren't just slinging or buying
product on the silk road you were now
part of a movement
just like how cuba fought for communism
under che guevara and how creative
hipsters fought to think differently
under steve jobs
the war on drugs now had dread pirate
roberts also known as dpr also known as
captain
and after only one year in business ross
ulrich was now a millionaire
and it was around this time that a
corrupt dea agent joins the hunt
it's 2012 and ross was now making so
much money that he was having a hard
time laundering all of it into cash
back in december he was making 500 000
in sales a month
by march he was hitting 500 dollars in
sales in a week
at this rate it would be a million in
sales every week and worst case scenario
2012 would be a 100 million
a year for the company and by 2013 it
would be a billion dollar year
ross was now making 10 000 a day in fees
and thanks to bitcoin going up in price
his net worth was doubling or tripling
every few weeks
it was around this time that corrupt dea
agent karl force creates an anonymous
account on the silk road named knob and
starts chatting with ross posing as a
professional criminal
and now it was time to monetize the site
even more every founder and startup goes
through this phase
they introduce a new feature to make
them more money a paywall adds higher
prices etc the users go mad but
eventually get over it and ross went
through the same thing
the original fee structure for sellers
was a flat 6.23
commission for every sale made no matter
how large or small now it was bumped up
to a 10
commission for orders less than 50
dollars and 1.5 percent for orders over
a thousand
smaller deals were outraged ross didn't
understand because in his eyes
if it wasn't for him they would still be
risking their lives selling in the
streets but eventually they got over it
back in 2004 ross made a silent deal
with himself that by age 30 he would be
a billionaire
at this point he was 28 and a
multi-millionaire and at the hockey
stick growth they were headed on that
dream of becoming a billionaire by age
30 was starting to look pretty realistic
ross realized that this website would be
his life's work his legacy
the next goal post was a billion dollars
in sales in a year and to do that they
were going to need to expand
ross's business partner argued that they
should open a second website just for
selling those things that shoot a
projectile at a high speed that youtube
doesn't like you talking about he argued
that these products scared off
mainstream customers
that we needed a dedicated website for
them so the grandma looking to buy her
meds wouldn't trip over a glock in the
aisle
dread pirate roberts dpr would also
approve the sale of poison
and body parts that were apparently
acquired consensually it was around this
time that a bunch of government agencies
wanted in on the case all of a sudden
one of them would be fbi special agent
chris tarbo that would eventually arrest
ross
nicknamed the elliot ness of online
crime after the guy that took down al
capone
and then things started getting really
shitty on both dpr's side and the law
enforcement side
[Music]
meanwhile in utah corrupt dea agent carl
force also known as knob
raised the house of a silk road
moderator named curtis green curtis
green had an account with a lot of
access
so the agent uses his account to steal
350 000
of bitcoin from dpr not as an official
seizure but for his own personal pocket
posing as the moderator he just arrested
so dpr was put in a tough spot
on one hand the amount of money stolen
wasn't too much compared to how much
money he was bringing in but on the
other hand if he didn't retaliate
against his moderator
it would show the community that you can
steal from the boss without any
repercussions
so in just eight words dpr sanctioned
the first murder for the silk road
and who pretends to accept that hit job
the same corrupt cop that just arrested
that moderator for forty thousand
dollars up front and another forty
thousand dollars after the hit was done
dea agent carl force was now a double
agent and would go on scamming dpr for
around seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars in total
i'm playing both sides so that i always
come out on top
after all why not it was the opportunity
of a lifetime since he had all the
access and bitcoin was anonymous
for dpr a hundred thousand dollars here
to get tipped off about the cops
half a million dollars there for an
assassination was just the cost of doing
business
[Music]
you leave thousands of fingerprints
behind you every single time you're
online even if you're careful
ross was no different and those
fingerprints started to pile up ross had
ordered nine fake ids to his place in
san francisco that ended up being
intercepted by law enforcement they
didn't suspect he was a silk road
founder yet
but now they had his location and photo
then an irs agent found an old post that
was made on the site stack overflow
which developers used to ask coding
questions it was a coding question about
torah made by a user with the name ross
albrecht before the user name was
changed to frosty
the fbi uncovers the server's ip address
through a misconfiguration with the
captcha element on the silk roads login
page
you know these annoying things that
server was also named frosty and that
ipaddress led right back to ross in san
francisco
dhs agent jared gets a hold of another
moderator's account
to monitor dpr's activity with all the
signs pointing to ross ulbricht the fbi
started stalking him before moving in
for the attack
the only problem was they needed to
catch him on his laptop logged in or
else they may never be able to decrypt
the laptop and prove that he was indeed
dread pirates roberts
[Music]
ross ulrich was arrested exactly at 3 16
pm on october 1st 2013
a day earlier than planned at the time
he had been renting a room in san
francisco for a thousand dollars a month
which is strange to say the least for a
future billionaire
that afternoon he headed out and
searched for better wi-fi and a change
of scenery
never thinking that a team of fbi agents
were circling his block
after finding most of his usual spots
overcrowded ross headed for the glen
park library
the fbi arrested ross william ulbricht a
san francisco resident in a public
library
the secretive dread pirate roberts was
arrested in the most
unlikely of places this local public
library in this san francisco
neighborhood
306 pm ross sat down at a library table
and started up his laptop
308 undercover agent jared made contact
on the silk road chat hoping to get ross
to sign into the sites
3013 a female undercover agent took a
seat at ross's table
3 14. ross logged into the silk road
admin and special agent tarbell gave the
go order
3 15. an undercover agent yelled fu in
the quiet library to create a
distraction
ross stood up trying to figure out what
was going on and within seconds the
agent sitting next to ross slips his
laptop away from him
before ross could react someone grabs
his arms from behind and the fbi swarms
in guns blazing
316 ross is cuffed and his laptop seized
ross was transported to the alameda
county jail his laptop was being
carefully backed up dozens of times in
as many different
ways as the fbi team could think of ross
aroused in new york for his trial and
was held in the same cell that al qaeda
terrorists and mafia boss john gotti
were held in
ross got a famous lawyer that has
defended some of the most notorious
criminals on american soil and he turned
down a plea deal for 10 years to life
still certain that he would win but then
ross pleaded this in his final statement
i've had my youth and i know you must
take away my middle years but please
leave me my old age
please leave a small light at the end of
the tunnel an excuse to stay healthy
an excuse to dream of better days ahead
and a chance to redeem myself in the
free world before i meet my maker
but in the end the government showed no
mercy the biggest criminal trial in the
history of the internet
is over this morning and so apparently
is ross ulrich's freedom
the dread pirate roberts was now 30
years old but instead of being a
billionaire as he hoped he was found
guilty on all seven felony counts and
was sentenced to two life sentences plus
40 years in prison without parole
as a first-time nonviolent offender a
sentence that is unheard of for cyber
crime
he said mom it's a death sentence it
just takes longer and he's right
this is for all non-violent charges this
is what the judge had to say about her
decision
she actually explicitly said in her
statement that she wanted to send a
message with us the prosecution asked
for that she said yes
this was unprecedented i'm going to set
a precedent so that any other
you know potential young online online
drug lords
will think twice about following in in
your misguided footsteps as she said
the judge came back and was was said no
that this was you wanted this to be your
legacy right
right she said you want this to be your
legacy you wanted it to be your legacy
and now it is
i was trying to do something good i was
trying to help us move toward a freer
and more equitable world but we all know
the road to hell
is paved with good intentions right and
now here i am i'm in hell
the caricature they created was a
violent
lord that is not who i am
that is a lie it's a lie that was
carefully crafted to justify keeping me
in this cage
until i die it's a lie
designed to turn you against me
to turn your heart off
they stole two of them went to prison
over the ceiling
they destroyed evidence at one point
they were looking into how they could
give me the death penalty
the irony is that i made silk road in
the first place because
i thought i was furthering the things i
cared about
[Music]
freedom privacy quality
but by making silk road i wound up in a
place where those things
don't exist sometime later this century
i'll grow old and die i'll finally leave
prison but i'll be in a body bag
[Music]
when news broke of his life sends people
cheered you're breaking up the social
fabric
of our country they applauded when the
judge announced ross would be in jail
forever
this is the judge who finally got it
right right all right we all agree here
life in prison without parole anybody
else any other wise guys want to do it
that's what you're going to get
but the shutting down the silk road and
throwing ross in prison actually helped
eight years later
no not one bit it's not like they got
rid of these things
here's another one and by the way silk
road had twelve thousand listings when
uh it was taken down the news sites
offer more than a hundred thousand
so i guess they weren't scared by ross's
life sentence
as the judge said so they didn't stop
anything no they actually there was a
spike
after the sentence was given it had the
opposite effect it's a
travesty what's going on as for the
apparent assassinations
ross claims that law enforcement planted
the evidence in his laptop and no bodies
were ever found
i can see both sides so what's your
verdict if you think he's innocent or
should be at least led out of prison
you can sign the petition with the link
below that has almost 500 000 signatures
i signed it and i'm sure the trained
mafia can get it over 500k and you can
also donate and take action at
freeross.org
this is what his mother had to say when
i asked what the donations go towards
which i have no reason to doubt it's his
mom all the links are in the video
description below
so what do you think of ross is he a
hero is he a criminal do you think he
was just asking to get in trouble do you
sympathize with him let me know in the
comments below and guys i believe people
have a fundamental right to put whatever
they want in their body even if it's bad
for them which includes hard drugs i do
not endorse doing hard drugs in fact i
highly advise against it even though
it's your fundamental right
guys don't do drugs instead do genius
consciousness
like i mentioned i take genius
consciousness almost every single day i
do hard creative work because i feel the
edge it gives me when i take it versus
when i don't take it again a little hard
to explain in words but it really is a
night and day difference from when you
take it and when you don't take it and
i'm pretty confident that the roi that i
get from this the extra money that i
make
thanks to the extra creative power that
i have from taking this vastly outweighs
the small cost of this
and that is how you guys should think
about this stuff an investment into your
brain and your productivity
a lot of us invest money into
supplements for our muscles which is a
completely normal thing in society to do
i do it myself too that's a good thing
but why isn't it also normal to invest
in the stuff for our brain why is that
such a foreign concept when investing in
our brain has such an infinitely higher
roi in our modern economy compared to
investing in our muscles which is still
important so let's normalize
investing in our brain together be more
productive together while at the same
time helping yourself helping myself and
helping my good friend rob over at the
genius brand
by picking up genius consciousness with
the link below check it out i promise
you would not regret it also forgot to
mention i know this is a lot of plugs
but don't forget to check out the video
i collab with sliding about the
influencer economy with the link below
if you enjoy my videos you're gonna love
kaios if you're new to this channel we
make video essays just like this one
every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world of
business just like this video
on crime business power geopolitics
all the above all you have to do is
click that red button below and turn on
the notification bell too
if you want behind the scenes stuff the
in-life kind of stuff you can follow me
on instagram at jaketrend.io that is
going to wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you